et maintenant
non
les mots de passe
qu'est ce que vous lui avez mal lu sans
fauteuil [ __ ] belle des paroles énervé
il va tomber c'est pas bon du tout ça
fais attention je vais pas te faire mal
non plus quand même ouais comment ça va
laisser sa vie je me suis fait faire une
même coupe que toi la coupe bagnard pour
faire plaisir à deux bouts c'est bien
par la semaine dernière il aya même sur
ce plateau t'as vu l'émission non tu as
écouté leurs cd non j'aime pas la
démagogie donc moi je suis pas devant ma
tv c'est quoi ton présents pour parler
d'ailleurs les lits va te dire un truc
je jouais pas le budget a pas fini de
parler de merci parce que le crier
derrière toi tu as tous ces morceaux
j'ai tout est le morceau que tu préfères
dit non
un bisou et d un un bisou spyder v10 ou
allo
beaucoup de demandes devises ou faire
vivre je dis aux rudes jouer elle a fait
la même chose à akhenaton la semaine
dernière on va te faire car le cul
désert commence par beaucoup devises ou
10 mois avant que ouais t'as pas écouté
le cd de iamal mais aussi jamie choi
jeudi qui s'appelle jeudi jour de
sodomie à minuit chez noir et donc si
donc on passe au pas du rap français ou
promotionne de rap français dans tous
ses états et donc ouais j'ai écouté j'ai
écouté le maxi est de 3,2 siclaé l'album
on l'a reçue mais j'ai toujours
préoccupé ouais noble art c'est pas mal
non c'est quoi notre question à notre
question c'est toujours sur iam allons
les aider
on les a découvert un petit peu plus mûr
père de famille concernée par le monde
qu'ils allaient laisser à leur tranche
pas concernés à ce moment-là ça tu
n'étais pas concerné j'ai fait office
d'armand et de 1,2 fils avait refusé de
grandir at et a valu la discussion avec
le député de l'ump sur le sol cannabis
la cie ouais mais j'ai besoin de ça
alors ils veulent donner des amendes
soit dix mille balles soit 1000 mal
pourquoi c'est moi je te demande ça
parce qu'on a parlé pendant toute
l'émission de la semaine dernière et je
te demande ce que tu penses des amendes
pour les consommateurs de cannabis chez
mec tu consommes pas mais qu'est ce que
tu penses pour les mets qui consomment
pas de façon de toute façon je trouve
qu'il ya des mesures tu vois c'était
quoi je reprends la base la base du
projet de loi c'est leur prendre leur
véhicule rapporté volé le scooter de
combat c'est cependant lui et puis de
toute façon je pense que ça changera
rien en fait est que et qui on iran
corman aux urnes
j'entends qu'on est quoi bon prendre une
voix une par la grc rappelle que je suis
me vendre un dvd
c'est bien c'est un truc que j'aime pas
faire et ouais donc faisons le et puis
après on se dit des conneries ton qu'on
veut ouais tu le vends ton dvd un peu
oui
non c'est surtout en fait plutôt que de
le vente directe beaucoup de gens le
voient et quoi ouais sauf que si on
pouvait le diffuser sur les places
publiques ne seraient plus riches
oui oui c'est vrai sans faire payer
l'entrée bien sûr